the international trade committee will  look at the Commission's proposals on  restarting trade talks with the u.s.  members vote on boosting funding for the  erasmus+ programme in the next  multi-annual EU budget the new programme  aims to promote mobility and lifelong  learning the EU wants to reduce the  number of fatal and serious injuries and  road crashes by half between 2020 and  2030 members discuss vehicle safety  regulations including intelligent speed  assistance and driver drowsiness  monitoring the working group on rule of  law will reveal his conclusions after  the murders of journalists in Malta and  Slovakia Parliament commits to  safeguarding press freedom and fighting  corruption Parliament welcomes  representatives from Parliament's around  Europe for the European parliamentary  week 2019 participants will discuss  economic policy employment and the euro  [Music]